[Music]
I've been working with The Wall Street
Journal to develop their mobile website
for about the last 18 months or so and
it's difficult to develop for mobile can
I get a show of hands of people in here
who have developed for mobile devices
okay and raise your hands if you were
satisfied with how that experience went
all right one guy cool yeah
mobile development is still in its
infancy and still requires a pretty
solid understanding of this new
philosophy that underlies what these
devices do virtually all of us are
coming at mobile development from a
desktop background and we try to
approach mobile sites the same way that
we approach desktop sites and it's not
going to work so everybody knows what
this thing is I hope it's the meta
viewport tag and you can't have a mobile
optimized site without it and this is
what any tutorial that you look up in
Google is going to tell you to put they
don't really tell you exactly what it's
doing or why you need it they just tell
you that you need it and it's a little
more complicated than that because this
thing is powerful but it can also
configure your sites in weird ways and
it has so many exceptions that you will
have to wrestle with before it is able
to do its job so before we can talk
about width equals device width we have
to talk about what width means in a
mobile context when we started out on
the desktop we knew in the early days of
desktop development that we didn't know
exactly what screen resolution we were
going to be dealing with on you know the
user's machine we didn't know how wide
their browser was going to be on that
computer but the one thing we could
trust at the very least was that a pixel
on their screen was the same thing as a
pixel in their browser
was the same thing as a pixel in your
72dpi PSD which is the same thing as one
CSS pixel which is great and then this
came along and you had Retina displays
and you had pinch-to-zoom and that all
went out the window and to make things
worse you can't really get back to what
we had the simplicity of one pixel
equals one pixel instead you have to
free yourself from the concept of what a
pixel even means the viewport is a new
concept desktop browsers don't really
have a viewport unless you consider the
browser window itself to be a viewport
but I'm going to argue that especially
in the mobile context they are really
not the same thing
it's best to think of the viewport as a
hole that you are viewing your real
website through and that hole is
stretchable or maybe you can think of
the hole as getting closer or farther
away from the site but the viewport
despite what the user may think because
the user sees the viewport and thinks of
it as the browser window but the
viewport is not the browser window it's
a hole that you're looking at the
browser window through and that means
that when you make the viewport smaller
or bigger it's not the same thing as
making your browser window smaller or
bigger because on a fluid layout when
you make the browser bigger or smaller
the site moves up and down with it but
when you zoom in and out of your
viewport that doesn't happen so Apple
introduced Retina displays with the
iPhone 4 and they said look obviously we
don't want all of the mobile optimized
sites that have already been built to be
1/4 of the size on this new phone that
we've built so for the sake of this
phone four of the pixels on the screen
of this phone constitute one virtual
pixel or CSS pixel if you like but then
the ability to zoom the viewport beyond
that means that even that virtual pixel
is a fairly imprecise unit of
measurement so these are things that are
not going to help you if you're
developing a mobile site you can no
longer count
on these things being the same how many
pixels wide your site is what about the
screen what about your stylesheet they
could all be different the site could
display properly they could all be the
same in the site could display wrong and
there's a bunch of exceptions so there's
an invisible browser on the other side
of that hole it has no chrome but it's
there as you know with any regular
browser desktop browser when you squeeze
the browser all the way down two things
will happen one if it's a really liquid
layout it will actually reflow all the
way down as tight as you squeeze it but
more likely that website has a
hard-coded width set on it in which case
squeezing the browser window down is not
going to do anything but pop up a scroll
bar at the bottom or the layout could be
a fairly liquid layout but there could
be a picture or some element in there
that's fairly big and sooner or later
that is going to be the smallest that
that website is going to go so if you if
you want your website's to go all the
way down to 320 pixels you're gonna have
to make sure that there are no
hard-coded widths on your site and that
there are no elements in there that at
least in a mobile context are larger
than the invisible browser behind the
hole that you're trying to squeeze
things down that's what the width part
does it's talking about not the width of
the viewport which is just a piece of
glass but the width of the invisible
browser behind the viewport but what is
device width device-width is easy to
understand with an iPhone because Apple
is saying yeah so forget how many pixels
there really are there are 320 pixels as
far as you're concerned you the CSS
developer so the device width is 360
except that different mobile devices
will specify a different number for how
wide their device is that number bears
no resemblance to how many pixels wide
the screen is it could be one to one it
could be one point five to one one point
six six six repeating to one two three
could be anything
number device with its not listed
anywhere you'll have to query it somehow
with JavaScript or something or just
read up on the specs I guess although
they almost never list the device width
on the you know box and also when you
turn your phone sideways the device
width could change or it could stay the
same depending on what OS you're running
so what are we going to do with this
plura proliferation of device widths
because our mobile site depends on
telling our viewport to be the same
width as the device width or rather the
invisible browser behind the viewport to
be the width of your device you might
have a 320 pixel wide visual design that
looks like this and you might be able to
get it to look like this on a phone and
you might think oh I'm 80% done because
it looks like this on a phone are your
designers okay with how it's gonna look
on an Android device that has a device
width of 360 the banner ad is boots
banner ad is no longer flush to the
sides and the buttons on either side of
the logo are starting to spread out and
the even margins around the image are
starting to get uneven and then you go
up to a galaxy note and it gets worse
which again your designers may be able
to live with this you may show this to
them and they're like that's fine are
your designers fine with this when the
device width goes to 640 the designers
at the company that I work for are not
ok with this more to the point even if
the designers of your company are yeah
they can live with this you're still
going to get passive-aggressive emails
from your advertisers saying hey just
check the site on the iPhone the ads
look great but on the Android there's
some weird padding around the size of
the ads so if you can just fix that
that'd be cool
and I know what you're thinking you're
thinking yeah no problem I'm just gonna
throw some media queries on there and
I'll scale things up and I'll flush
things out and it's all going to be fine
really are you really going to add
another media query every time another
Android comes out with another screen
size because I can guarantee you three
more Android devices were announced
while I was giving this talk I'm sure
this is not a scalable solution you
can't just have a media query that just
gets longer and longer as your site gets
older or I guess maybe you'll get to
edit some of the ones off the top as
those devices have browser shares that
you know drop low enough that you don't
have to support them anymore there is
another way The Wall Street Journal site
that I built for mobile doesn't use any
media queries and it doesn't use any
Android style sheets it's one site that
displays exactly the same on all
browsers but to achieve that you have to
understand how these different browsers
think because each of them has quirks
each of them has things that really
don't work and yet they're broken in
really different ways that reflect the
mentality behind the OS and the browser
that they ship with so everybody
remembers this guy Apple tends to have a
approach when it comes to building
things which is find the best possible
solution polish it as much as you can
release it and then try to prevent
anyone from using any other way of doing
it that seems to have worked out pretty
well for them so far but what's best for
apples users might not be best for the
developers when I rotate my web browser
sideways on a phone the browser scales
up the site even though I didn't really
ask it to do that and there's no
checkbox that makes it stop doing that
but you know apples helping you some of
you may know this guy Doug Bowman was a
Google designer who quit in 2009 kind of
publicly and he ran afoul of Google's
engineering driven mindset and an
approach that I guess you could
summarize as put it out first and we'll
update it in github later you know it's
you know will
thinker with it as we go it's very
markedly different from Apple's approach
well you have to keep in mind when
you're troubleshooting these two
different browsers and I understand
their other mobile browsers out there
but this is a 25-minute talk so Mobile
Safari original goal when it was
introduced was to make desktop sites
navigable on a tiny viewport it wasn't
to make mobile optimized sites easy to
use or easy to build for that matter so
you will be working against this bias
when you try to build a mobile site
because a lot of the things that the
browser is doing are geared towards
desktop sites Android on the other hand
was released after the iPhone had
already achieved like a 95 percent
market share when it was the only game
in town and so their goal was to rapidly
make up for lost time and a lot of their
original quirks and presets and default
behaviors were based on essentially
trying to masquerade as an iPhone for
lack of a better word I don't know how
many of you have dealt with trying to
make sites work on a android gingerbread
device that's two point three point X
that device is I guess you could say
intentionally if not maliciously broken
the user agent does not contain the
words Android or Google making it almost
impossible to detect the screen
resolution when queried will lie and say
that it's 3:20 unless you refresh the
page and then it'll be correct I can
only assume that in their zeal to catch
up to Apple that Google kind of played
you know hard and fast with the specs
and said it's okay because you know
we'll update it later and it'll be fine
and you know Android 4.1 is pretty good
but they started from a really bad place
and some of that cruft is still in the
browser now I don't want to make it
sound like this is just a big Android
but that is going to be mostly
the rest of my talk
so of this fully fleshed out meta
viewport tag
you've got your wits equals device with
you've got an initial scale value I'm
sure most of you guys have played with
initial scale equals zero because that's
what everyone tells you to use minimum
scale maximum scale user scalable which
of these will Android devices
consistently conform to not one of them
every single one of these can be ignored
under certain circumstances depending on
what Android feels it wants to do with
equals device width is good if your site
is wider than the device width but it'll
ignore it if it's less than the device
width so it's like okay half the time
you can set user scalable to know but if
you then set a scale on the site it says
oh I guess user scaling is on because
you just changed the scale and you're
like no user scaling is off developer
scaling should be on but no it's getting
better but it's still very frustrating
to work with and as you guys know
androids installed user base upgrades
very slowly usually in two year cycles
so even though 4.1 is out now I don't
know how many years it's going to be
before all of the people with
Gingerbread devices get rid of their
phones and upgrade to the next one on
the other hand it's probably okay if you
check your browser stats you'll probably
find that no one is hitting your site
using a gingerbread Android browser
probably because they can't get to your
site hold it what about the target
density dpi
if you've ever developed for mobile
you've run up against this one everyone
says that just like width equals device
width you should set it to device DPI
and all your problems will go away your
problems will not go away for one thing
that is a deprecated attribute it was
removed from WebKit by Apple last year
and I can only assume that future
versions of Android will also drop
support for it I guess right now it is
the only attribute that works reliably
to style your site all of the rest of
them are basically just for Iowa
this is the only one that counts on
Android I can't explain why that is but
thank me later don't set it to device
DPI I don't know why set it to one sixty
I can't tell you why to set it to one
sixty but if your site is 320 pixels
wide and you tell your Android to have
target density dpi 160 it will render a
320 pixel sight at the full width of the
screen on just about any device dpi
device that you're working with 430 6321
60 should work like 89% of the time the
rest of the time on the Wall Street
Journal we detect those devices that are
edge cases and we give them 140 which is
apparently the other number that works
for them I don't know why this is so
this is a really good starting point for
your mobile site all of these other ones
are for Apple the maximum and minimum
scale set to 1 will disable the zooming
that's a nice thing that Apple did for
us developers prior to iOS 5 you
couldn't disable the zooming no matter
what you did technically that zooming is
provided by the operating system not the
browser I would argue but it was nice of
them to say ok if we see that in your
meta tag we'll go ahead and not zoom for
you so that half of the meta tag makes
your phone behave more like an Android
device which does not Otto's oom when
switching orientations and then the
target density dpi makes the site fit
properly on a wide variety of Android
screens there are some problems that
remain problems that are not solved by
that meta tag we're still in the really
early stages of mobile web support and
there are things that you're going to
have to deal with I've got a list of
some of my favorites here I can't even
tell you a reliable way to deal with
them some of them are really really
pernicious and I've got a couple extra
minutes I'm going to walk you through
what you're going to be up against if
you choose
to dive into the world of mobile
development WebKit overflowing scrolling
touch you guys may be familiar with that
property that's what allows a div on the
page to scroll independently of the rest
of the page people use it for nav bars
they use it for slideshows they use it
for all kinds of things it works pretty
well in iOS 5 and above and Android 4
and above except if there's an iframe
anywhere on the page and this is a
WebKit bug it affects all the WebKit
browsers and if there's an iframe
anywhere not in the scrollable div
anywhere on the page the page will
freeze and stop being interactive and
people will get mad at you
fixing it is really really difficult for
The Wall Street Journal we have a lot of
iframed ads in our content but we use
overflow scrolling touch on our Facebook
style nav bar I'm using my phone itself
for the presentation so I'll pull out
this galaxy s4 here is the same site
full width ads going all the way to the
side there's our oops come on there you
go so there's our scrollable div and
you'll notice that the iframes
momentarily disappeared when I opened it
up and now they're back again in order
to make that scrollable area work I have
to detach all iframes from the Dom save
where they are open the apply this style
to the day of only then because if the
style co exists at any moment with an
iframe anywhere on your page the page
will die but if you don't apply the
style and you wait until the user throws
the event then you quickly detach all
the iframes apply the style open the
drawer
now it's scrollable and then when you
close the drawer you detach the style
reinstate all the iframes and you don't
get angry calls from your advertisers
asking why their ads are gone WebKit
transform scale applied to an iframe
will blow it up it'll scale to some
crazy amount that's a known bug in
webcam
affects all the mobile browsers that use
WebKit and I don't have the solution for
that other than just don't try to scale
an iframe it's not going to work
Android will trigger landscape
orientation media queries when the
keyboard opens because Android is a dick
the reason it does this is because
technically when your keyboard opens the
remaining available viewport is slightly
wider than it is tall
so Android goes well now we must be in
landscape mode and come on you know
that's not what the user wants and you
know that's not what the developer wants
and it may be technically true but it's
really pedantic I consider it a bug and
yeah all of this stuff we've been seeing
with 3d transforms and all the you know
crazy stocking and overlays in Z
indexing problem on Android that is
tough to work around but when you have
you know flipped flipped cards and
overlaid sliding drawers and cubes and
things if there's a anchor tag anywhere
anywhere in the stack of divs behind
where your finger is tapping it'll go
ahead and click on that anchor tag for
you the only solution I can offer is to
set those two display:none when they're
not visible because there's no there you
shouldn't be able to tap on them right
the event should propagate only to the
elements that you're directly
interacting with but their tap Abul so
these are things that I don't have easy
solutions for be aware of them before
you go because I spent a lot of time on
Stack Overflow finding this stuff out
and I can at least save you guys a bit
of heartache so I'm gonna go straight to
questions
and thank you for your time okay so the
the question was are some of these bugs
fixed in Chrome for Android as opposed
to the stock browser which I guess was
just called browser in android and the
short answer is yes some of them Google
is always going to preferentially treat
their
Chrome browser over the kind of phone
vendor supported browser browser so I
can't tell you which of these are fixed
in which versions of Chrome for Android
but Chrome for Android will always have
the latest WebKit available for that OS
and it'll always perform a little bit
better because Google is biased towards
in and it always gives it the latest and
greatest so yes but probably some of
those bugs are still there I've seen
lots of angry threads on Stack Overflow
and other sites about development where
people are complaining that Google seems
to remember that they give Android away
for free they seem to not terribly
prioritize but bugs even known bugs I've
seen them stay unfixed for more than a
year more than two years in some cases
serious bugs that hamper your ability to
use the site but I think there's reason
to be optimistic if Google decides to
throw away the browser browser and just
standardize all forthcoming Android OS
is around their new WebKit chrome which
again they're trying to make their
WebKit even more modern than apples so
that's probably only going to be good
for Android users so I'm gonna say a
tentative yes to its it's a little bit
more advanced so the question is did we
develop a separate tablet version and
are we handling it different than mobile
the answer is we don't yet have a
separate tablet version but we will when
we expand this one mobile site into a
fully responsive site we are essentially
not building a Mobile's first platform
because of course there is a wsj.com
website right now but the mobile site
will essentially be expanded until it
contains everything on the desktop site
and then the desktop site will become
the responsive mobile site I mean we'll
stop calling it the mobile site at that
point our our browser stats have shown
that a lot of iPad users are perfectly
happy to just use the desktop site on
iPads they don't feel encumbered by the
somewhat smaller screen size they seem
okay with it so we haven't gotten a lot
of complaints by letting iPad or
their tablet users use the desktop site
people seem comfortable with it but we
are eventually going to just responsive
our way up where no matter what your
width is you'll get a user experience
that is customized to that particular
width so it's coming so the question is
how do you work with designers because
they too need to be educated on all of
the constraints and new concepts that
are associated with mobile development
and how do you get them the information
that they need how do you get the
information that you need from them
so I can only speak from my own
experience but at the Wall Street
Journal our visual designers are
essentially designing a 320 pixel wide
website but their PS DS are 640 pixels
wide because of Retina displays and so
they are developing I guess what you
could say 144 dpi 320 pixel wide except
it's not really pixels anymore comps
that's what they're developing their
developing 640 pixel Whitesides androids
now have a few devices like the one I
just showed you that has a stated device
DP device dpi of 3 sorry pixel ratio of
three not two but I think we're
approaching something below the limits
of human perception when you go over to
so I find that 2x sized images are
sufficient to always look crisp and just
about any any other Android device
usually the ones with a device width of
360 they are usually working with a 1.5
pixel ratio so you are serving slightly
higher res images than some of the
androids can use or for that matter an
iPhone 3GS can use but what people have
found is that you can compress the hell
out of retina sized images because the
JPEG compression artifacts will also
fall below the threshold of human
perception so you don't have to bloat up
your images quite as big as you think
you do you can compress them much more
heavily and when shrunk down using you
know CSS scaling they will still look
pretty
and not Jo Peggy at all but in terms of
what the designers need to know I don't
think it's possible for them to design
like this wide range of designs
especially at least the argument that
I'm making is don't accept the stated
width of 360 or 400 just force everybody
to use the same 320 pixel sight which
means everything is based on the same
640 pixel wide PSD everybody in the
design department knows all graphics
have to be 2x and the fonts have to be
set to double the size that they you
know think of them but again if you set
your PSD to 144 DPI you can still use
the same font point size that you would
normally use and yet when you flatten
out the image it'll it'll look exactly
right so I hope that answers your
question do I have any more questions no
oh what oh there's one excellent is it
is it called the HTC Jay 27 X to the
white Nexus 4 got it
well they that I think that happened at
least once didn't it that the white one
had a slightly not it can happen for any
Adobe people here
thanks for content-aware fill really
makes making these graphics a lot easier
thank you for your time
[Music]
you